[Musique]
là nous sommes sur la départementale 52
vont direction de grant hill est
le bélier
[Musique]
chaque jour on à la patrouille qui fait
une tournée pour nous signaler si un
problème sur le réseau
[Musique]
sa a dégagé la route à enlever les
branches fait le curage des fossés
enfin un peu du langage
débrancher les rapines
[Musique]
au ps dit ce qui se trouve juste en haut
là bas il ya quelques années ça il y
avait la route qui passait dans le coin
n'a pas l'aise la coupe de l'autre côté
et suite à des événements pluvieux du
mauvais temps si clown et caetera
donc il ya eu un glissement de terrain
la partie de la route qui se trouvait à
ses côtés là est partie donc on a fait
des travaux pour remettre une
outre de neuf juste en haut on a
travaillé quelques
quelques mois on va dire
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on peut dire que ben cette
route là les sécuriser et elle est
vraiment belle aussi voilà
[Musique]
mais
et
je
[Musique]